but guys for us on all the social media
Instagram Twitter Facebook fancy Foster
constant kissing trigger pod follow us
all that's on kill it already come on
follow us follow us follow us
hello beautiful bigots bigger testers
the cute little bigotini and of course
the entire bigotex Community welcome one
welcome all that is of course Tuesday
night and that means one thing and one
thing only it is raw yes welcome to the
Tuesday raw we've got so much good news
to tell you from all across the glove so
many positive things going on in the
world at this moment that we just can't
hold back any longer we can't indeed but
first of all Francis we hit 400 000
subscribers uh over the weekend that is
absolutely fantastic four hundred
thousand bigots on YouTube alone
correction we've now just hit 411 000
and it's going up massively so to all
those bigots who've just joined where
the [ __ ] were you why have you just
joined now of your game good question
Francis by the way do you know that
almost two-thirds of people who watch
our content are not subscribed
cement with you what's wrong with you
why don't you've got a [ __ ] spine
spout
exactly
that's why he was invited to do Oxford
Union because he's our ticket articulate
and eloquent strap on a pair is the
phrase I was looking for exactly smash
the Subscribe button smash the like
button send us a Super Chat subscribe on
local send us a paper I'll do all those
things because we have a [ __ ] amazing
show for you it is in the words of our
top level supporter Nathan Woodard The
Greatest Show on Earth exactly and we
know there's loads of birds who don't
want to subscribe because you're worried
what people will think because you love
a bit of the old trans banter and you
don't because people might find out
doesn't matter [ __ ] subscribe drop on
a pair as well come on you're all Angry
lesbians anyway exactly you're gonna end
up in the gulag anyway
with Nicola they're going right who's
the first one to receive my fist you
know what there will be quite a lot of
people following my Oxford Union speech
who are here for the first time I think
we've given them a fair impression of
what raw is all about I think so and I
think they're going to love it mate I
think this is the exact kind of content
that they're tuning in for in fact one
of our fans I think it might have been
Mr Sean T said my favorite thing about
trigonometry is watching new subscribers
click on raw and get absolutely
horrified by what's happening yeah you
get a nice little conservative ladies in
America oh this nice Christian boy I
mean
and then they tune into this filth yeah
there's no Gammon phase during the
Gammon cam by the way do you know that
since we've come back from New Year
you've not even done a Gammon cam I
haven't done a Gammon cam not to give
everybody a game okay right you mean G
little snacks there are so many of you
who are watching this show but you would
be scared you would be worried what will
people think it doesn't matter you're
gonna lose your friends anyway subscribe
to the channel accept yourself into the
cult send me money
well said my friend well Francis uh we
should talk about dogs for Union speech
we should do we should do because that
is uh I think it's over probably I'm
guessing it's hard to say at this point
around 40 to 50 million views wow world
whoa over 3.3 on our channel uh two on
my own Twitter and then a [ __ ] ton of
people have shared it and retweeted it
and put it on TV and all sorts of things
I will be doing some big TV shows over
the next couple of days talking about it
as well yep so let's just uh I think
it's fair to say it's done reasonably
well yeah it's done very well are you
looking forward to your stint on
Guardian TV absolutely mate they're not
in the viral media I'm sure it's an
invitation from the viral media is
incoming shortly I would love you for
you to go so would I would destroy them
just like I'd destroy the students but
um you know what's I mean it's something
that I always think about in these
situations you know what's fascinating
well not a single mainstream publication
has contacted me to for an interview
really no not a single one the only
people who've contacted me for uh for uh
uh GB news yeah in this country a load
of podcasts yeah um and uh every show on
Fox News
every single one and there's anyone been
in contact uh no they did a they did an
article about it okay actually
um yeah and I just I think it just shows
you how did disconnected the mainstream
media are from what's going on I just
also think they're all [ __ ] they're
all terrified they don't want to talk
about it in any particular way uh in any
way that a contravention narrative
which actually is their duty but what
narrative you see with my speech what
narrative did I contrave didn't deny
climate change in fact I said if you
believe in it this is the way to fix it
right
what narrative what what is the
narrative that they they they're trying
to stick to what did I say that was
controversial this is what I don't get
loads of people are like oh your speech
is so brave what
what did I say I didn't say this is this
is the funny world we live in it's like
it's so easy to do my job because I just
say some obvious things and people are
like oh my God I haven't heard this
before yes because people aren't saying
the obvious [ __ ] that we all know yeah
because people are terrified right
that's how it works yeah so you terrify
people into existence so it's like when
you do comedy about you know a
particular subject like I know every
single comedians
approach to for instance the gender
build the uh gender recognition bill in
Scotland I know what every single
comedian will say before before they say
oh it's so great and in fact I am
transitioning right now oh they'll say
it's a minority issue trans people are
0.0 or whatever percent of the
population
and you know does this and we want one
of them in every women's bathroom
exactly but it goes widely spread them
evenly across Scotland yeah uh but and
so they're going to make that point but
they're not going to address the other
point
which are the more important ones
somebody called kiss the sky in the chat
says they're staring into the camera is
disconcerting they're not going to make
it no they're not you're not going to
survive raw if you don't find it
comfortable for us to be looking like
this
hello if you can't handle that then your
slags you don't belong here anyway yeah
welcome one welcome all send us your
Super Chat what did you think about the
speech what do you want us to talk about
sending the paypals of course and we
will be reacting to your questions and
suggestions very shortly you know but
you know Rogan made this point well he
made it through uh basically through uh
regarding comedy but
it's now the easiest time ever to be a
comedian yeah because if you've got
balls if you've got balls then you just
go what's going on with this and you
just present the other side of it and
everyone's like oh I've never heard this
before [ __ ] Rings the only thing that
you you should say though is it's easy
to be a comedian if you have your own
audience yeah right or if you're
building one online yeah if you want to
play The Comedy circuit oh you're [ __ ]
yeah you know yeah but then again no one
in their right Minds wants to play The
Comedy circuit if they can help it yeah
um
yeah Rogan's right I mean he's right and
the same with Santa and the same with
anything all you have to do is just you
know my joke about you know my wife got
pregnant not me because we're old school
that is not a clever joke no it is an
obvious joke but people laugh at it
because no one wants to do that joke um
exactly now what see because everybody's
terrified like when people legitimately
have conversations which reference the
word her penis
and you just go well she doesn't have
one and if she does it's a bloke yeah
and everyone's like that's controversial
I'm like
really not
really not that controversial at all
it's kind of year two three biology
you know exactly let's find out what all
the beautiful bigots are saying in the
chat by the way Francis we did have a
little paypalio come in over the last
couple of days from somebody
um let me find it because it was a 150
quid 150 knicker good boy rest of you
[ __ ] take notes and Melissa has sent
us 391 says a question to a podcaster on
YouTube and then didn't ask a question
oh it says Francis would you please
explain in detail what happened to
Venezuela's economy well the Latinos
they don't like working they don't like
working do you know what I mean it's too
nice to work there go over there every
you know the river's lovely it's
basically a paradise apart from the
mosquitoes and birds are incredible the
birds are incredible why would you work
it's all a nonsense no it's communism
basically that's what just what I'm
you're putting communism everyone goes
this is going to be brilliant and it
just that's why I'm so every Communist
Regime yeah for weight loss mate so
that's it is it is great for weight loss
you know what it is you know you you
lose a [ __ ] ton of weight it's all good
anyway I mean it's not we've now got a
problem to uh poverty right of 96 which
is obviously a travesty well you're at
least you're succeeding in some
categories exactly of course one of the
largest migrant populations in the world
if not the largest we were largest at
one point I don't know if we if Yemen
have overtaken us again winners yeah
we're winners lovely next
uh number five is a line of office
Canadians I would love to see Darren
McGarvey on here too
you're gonna tell us to interview people
we've already interviewed yeah
it's a brilliant interview going trick
here go and watch it yeah it's called
something he's whining about the poor
and that we obviously don't care well of
course he does yeah exactly yeah we're
joking it was a great interview with
Darren McGarvey go and check it out yeah
it's brilliant it's a great interview it
is let's do it with the two quid says
what do you call a female police officer
with a shaved Fanny constable
oh my word I think I heard that even
Anton didn't like that that's about we I
actually shook his head like this I
heard I've never seen him turn down a
pun he's from Liverpool that is true
um that was a joke from 1991. thank you
very much cheers
uh MMD with a 10 euros great speech at
Oxford you assuming he's Irish I'm
assuming he's the Irish because he's
speaking because it's in the Euro and
he's talking in English
walkness has infected the Indian
intellectual class already okay so I got
it a bit wrong no I'm not sure he's
Indian though I mean they don't use
Euros in India no why don't you put on
the Indian hat yes and do the Irish
accent okay then we've got all our bases
covered so great speech at Oxford
walkness has infected the Indian
intellectual class already endangering a
socio-economic reality that is not
wealthy enough to afford it thanks for
making this point you're welcome MMD
thank you very much for that uh
we will read this in the Swedish Viking
accent he says romance Jeremy Clarkson
is getting canceled on both channels
despite apology did he again just prove
why you never apologize uh we've
actually got an article on that Sven if
we've got the time we will address your
point if further
um there is there's two versions of this
story one is that he's being canceled
and the other one is that he has got a
huge deal with Amazon that he's failing
to justify hence Amazon aren't renewing
it ah interesting that's the other one
by the way uh Jenny J says why is there
a raw today the two reasons number one
we sometimes do a raw on a Tuesday when
we have time number two I cannot be here
on Thursday and so we're doing this in
standard of the Thursday raw Sven thank
you very much for the 50 Norwegians
oh yeah
if the walk watch this the bigger thing
it will be exiled
now mate look the guardian I've been
watching for a long time they're doing a
little Rapport aren't they thank you
Silas for the two dollars much
appreciated inspector closure oh
not the 15 is a five but they're pounds
but he's in spectacles or from France he
says is Charles pooping his pants
I don't think so by the way Francis we
haven't even talked about the money oh
we sparkster was in here today Dr David
Starkey and you know we thought we'd
bring him in talk about how much Harry's
and Mindy little slag yeah right we had
a fascinating conversation about history
about the future of the western world
and about the fact that Harry Harry is a
mingy little slag and by the way uh he's
very chipper about the future of the
monarchy wasn't he he was very cheap
about the future of the monarchy and we
also discussed why the monarchy is so
important for England and nationalism TV
by the way says this is all painfully
not funny
mate stop letting your mum in the chat I
know mate nationalism TV yeah that is
that if your mum had a TV channel I'm
not right to see someone nationalist
just one more country with more people
in it as long as I stay in their country
that's fine
there we go uh thank you very much for
that uh Rick hey
would you be a challenge
please interview Prince Harry to rip him
apart Megan already does that for him
exactly thank you Ricardo appreciate the
two Mike Rogers congrats on the 400k the
Oxford Union video was bang on this but
this uh the the iceberg is going to
treat me to his bird there is bird I
don't know what does that mean don't
know mate he's going to treat me to some
tricks trick merch for my birthday in a
couple of weeks lovely stuff cheers Mike
thanks Mike congratulations to the is
bird
in order of the Church of trigonometry
thank you very much Carl thank you very
much let's get some Brazilian Flags in
the chat for the wonderful Carl uh let's
get some carnivals what else can we get
it's a Brazilian butt lifts what have
you been seeing what's happening in
Brazil with Joe bolsonaro's uh
supporters yeah they had a January the
sixth month yeah they did yeah exactly I
mean but to be honest with you right in
in South America that's just like
Wednesday I mean by the way we've got
loads of Brazilians in the chat you know
that and they're all deeply offended
they've got a sense of humor they love
it thank you very much for that uh Carl
I appreciate it uh Silas Larson is
another two dollars is
angry Moshi peas with chips
I don't have mushy peace mate man you're
an opener you love Moshi peas don't you
you're not a northern he's a scouse he's
not the same thing
I mean they're both you know a different
Beast yeah right but they're beasts we
mean unemployed next
Ollie W with a 99 uh love you speak to
the Oxford Union debate we've watched
too many times to take my money now
thank you very much yeah um by the way
someone says Francis moved to the right
a bit your face is covered by the
writing yeah that's on purpose yeah
bezel with the 449 says Gammon cam is
the way to preach I don't know why I did
that in American action bezel thank you
very much for being here and for your
support yeah perfect stuff
[Music]
love your videos keep it up why do you
always do that gesture with your hands
because that will be the screenshot me
face palming and you going yes while
reading an Israeli Super Chat
thank you very much Heim I appreciate it
uh Davis or the Eastern European let's
do it by the way Allah to be an employee
was explaining to me today that latvians
the northeastern Europeans the northern
European no that Eastern Europe correct
that's what I said she didn't like it no
she's fired uh Davis Willems with the
five euro says I am incredibly proud of
UK that they're sending thanks to
Ukraine slav Ukraine yes indeed Britain
is sending Challenger two tanks to
Ukraine uh along with a few other
countries uh the United States is
sending Ahmed uh Bradley Bradley uh
armored fighting vehicles uh the even
the Germans and the French might send
something well the French are going to
send something probably not no I mean no
they are they're sending someone they're
called mortar I think is what they call
it probably used yeah so I agree with
you Davis uh it's good to see the UK
continues to lead from the front in
supporting Ukraine in defending itself
thank you very much Diego Moretz these
are also Brazilians hey not the Oxford
speech you guys rock we in Brazil
unfortunately lost something speech what
are the dictators in power she is from
Brazil we've really got to work on a
Portuguese accident yes because that is
deeply offensive imagine someone just
said oh you're from England and you're
from England
I wouldn't give a [ __ ] good luck that's
true we'd laugh yeah it's because we
have a sense of humor yeah exactly all
right anyway thank you uh
Christa Holquist
became a YouTube member thanks Krista
Krista welcome home thank you so much
for that appreciate it Silas Larson says
fought true Joy see shagged by a rare
pirate BBC vid thank you very much
for you can I ask you something mate you
send in about 53 super chats every raw
that are two dollars why don't you just
send one that's twenty dollars save over
save everybody a bit of reading you know
what I mean no because he loves being
interactive yeah he does thank you so
much I appreciate it uh Trish's kitchen
oh my god with the Americans where is my
American hat there you go man all right
[ __ ] yeah all right love the Oxford
speech it's terrifying how afraid of
words we have become where did critical
thinking go we need some serious
re-engineering
thank you very much Trisha's kitchen
much appreciated thank you so much for
that oh it's there you find your mind
yeah let's go give it to me Patricia
bottomley with 8.99 says subscribe to
and proud top level bird you are
Patricia thank you thank you for
Patricia
uh Andrew Joyner with a free Nick of
thanks Andrew
uh Alan Hyde with a Fiverr
what is that funny what does it 20
months in my speech I misspoken instead
of weeks I said months I was talking
about the fetus yeah what is it 20 month
feet is that like Constantine card
Schwab I'm guessing probably something
along those lines yeah indeed all right
Francis
that is it I believe so far why don't we
talk about the Jeremy Clarkson stories
okay I brought it up I can't remember
one of them tuned scandinate one of the
two Vikings Tony let's have the Jeremy
Clarkson story I believe it was in I
can't remember if it was in the
telegraph sorry
yes in the Telly here we go here we go
the real reason behind Amazon's Jeremy
Clarkson cancellation the controverty
Around The Grand Tour toasts Duchess of
Sussex column hides a simple fact his
huge Amazon contract no longer makes
sense
of being [ __ ] basically yeah Amazon is
reportedly ending his contract with
Jeremy Clarkson in what appears to be
another intervention in the culture wars
except that may not be entirely the case
the original story in Hollywood trades
Bible variety reported that the
presenter is likely to part ways with
animals and following the conclusion of
existing agreements there's another
series of The Grand Tour and another two
of Clarkson's farm on the way but
variety claims the streaming giant won't
be commissioning the curmudgeonly
columnist beyond that is this as many
assume a moral stance over his desire
for it wasn't a desire to throw
excrement it was a metaphor you [ __ ]
idiots of his desire for crowds to throw
excrement at Meghan Markle while the
presenter admitted that Amazon were
incandescent over his controversial
column in the sun there are other
reasons for the deal to end it's true
that the streaming service won't be
working with Clarkson
Beyond seasons of The Grand Tour in
Clarkson's farm that have already been
commissioned this does mean however that
he'll be on screen in one form or
another
until 2025 one senior figure connected
to Amazon told the telegraph that any
speculation that this has anything to do
with like that
Harry Megan Megan is nonsense Amazon is
yet to confirm or deny the reports
Amazon's only interest in anything it
makes or sells is does it make a profit
says one media analyst this is a company
that sells mein cam for the Communist
Manifesto the big book of serial killers
and Prime Video has a documentary on
Charles Manson's final words I don't
think Jeremy Clarkson is quite in that
League uh Amazon was under No Illusion
about Clarkson's controversial behavior
when it signed the former Top Gear
presenter for a very healthy 160 million
knicker back in 2016. he'd been sacked
by the BBC in 2015 for punching one of
Top Gear's producers in the face after
being told the team's Hotel couldn't
prepare clogs in a sirloin steak late at
night political correctness gone mad
mate you can't even punch a producer for
not delivering steak exactly I mean you
can't punch a producer here because
Anton would deck both of us but still
exactly and the sirloin at least have a
[ __ ] rib off yeah go for the rib eye
man what we've got who wants a [ __ ]
sirloin exactly you're punching someone
over a salon what are you doing it's not
even a fill it anyway co-presented James
May later explained the fracker by
comparing Clarkson and Co to The Rolling
Stones Led Zeppelin or professional
footballers I really don't think you're
anything like Led Zeppelin mate uh
Clarkson's problem from Amazon's point
of view is that he's very expensive and
doesn't rate well outside the UK the
streamer has a relatively healthy 12
million Subs over here but boasts 200
million worldwide of which 75 are based
in the US and Carlson's Farm is simply
not a hit in America according to Global
audience measurement company para
analytics demand for Clarkson's Farm is
30 lower than demand for the average
show in the USA and for parrot 64 of all
shows fit into the average demand window
putting jezza in the bottom 20 of all
shows watched in America with Amazon
shedding subscribers in the UK his core
Market he's struggling to justify
reported 10 million pound salary The
Grand Tour is different it was once
popular in the US according to Parrot
figures but for the future of streaming
it's just the wrong show and it was
already grinding to a halt when the deal
was first signed back in 2016 Amazon
agreed to shut out 80 million dollars
per season for 36 episodes over three
years short in a tent that initially
traveled the world involving a hundred
crew members just to set up and operate
the tent and a small canvas Town set up
around it with production office Kitchen
Tech equipment and dressing room it
rapidly downsized to a Cotswold base
once the 36 episodes were finished
Amazon shifted the show to a series of
on the road specials Loosely grouped
under two seasons but the enormous cost
of flying huge teams around the world to
crash cars in a series of widely spaced
one-off doesn't fit the current
streaming Market all right should we
leave it there yeah all right so there
you go so you didn't actually can't get
canceled uh well according to this
anyway for the comments that he maybe
got canceled for not doing the business
yeah which is a pretty good reason to
cancel someone I suppose yeah exactly
not performing because and what they say
there it makes it makes a lot of sense
in the UK Clarkson is a huge star with a
massive fan base and people love him and
they really get on board with him I
can't imagine he'd be that popular in
America and so it shows I can't imagine
Americans really getting Jeremy Clarkson
but the point that I think Sven or or or
Silas raised was about apologizing
irrespective of why his Amazon stuff has
been canceled do you think he should
have apologized for what he said if he
felt that he did wrong then yes he
should have apologized very clearly from
his apology I don't think he felt that
he'd done anything wrong okay then he
shouldn't have done no
that is actually very simply put exactly
how you should do things if you believe
that you've done nothing wrong you
shouldn't apologize and if you believe
you've done something wrong which
sometimes you do like I remember a few
months ago I said something on whatever
it was about another comedian and she
complained about it on Twitter and I was
like you know what actually she's got a
point so I apologize because I was wrong
and she was right to to raise it now as
it turned out she didn't want my apology
she wanted to collect some attention
however it doesn't sound like a comedian
no it doesn't but however she I was
still right to apologize yeah and she
was still right to criticize me for what
I said right on the other hand in Jeremy
Clarkson's case why I don't understand
why none of these situations they just
don't come out and go it was a [ __ ]
metaphor
I mean it probably wouldn't I do
actually because the more you speak the
more they're going to misrepresent and
the more that their story is going to be
created as a result of doing that so it
doesn't matter what you say
you say engaging with someone in bad
faith like we know they're just going to
twist your words until we
it's pointless it's pointless to even
attempt an apology to a lot of those
people it's just not going to work there
we go guys keep the super chats coming
keep the paypals coming this it's what
keeps the show interactive keep sending
them in Anton let's find out what else
we got before we pick another story to
talk about James Beaver Fiverr I suggest
getting Alex Epstein on to talk about
climate change it's an issue we've
covered pretty well Mallon Baker
bjornberg Michael schellenberger
um who else have we had uh Roger Hallam
Roger yeah the co-founder of Extinction
Rebellion yeah he probably didn't enjoy
my speech quite as much
I like them as well but you'll be at my
door throwing painting my face probably
you're probably bloating himself to my
wife yeah
I mean that would be an interesting
anyway Patrick I'm Patrick Moore as well
absolutely I mean we've covered every
base there oh and marantupi and we did
have Marion tupi by the way what an
incredible interview that was yeah it
was great uh so we've covered that issue
very very well I'm sure we'll get Alex
Epstein on at some point uh I'm pretty
comfortable that I kind of know what my
thoughts are on climate change at this
point but doesn't mean we won't get
someone else to talk about it James
thank you very much for the Fiverr yep
thank you next
uh Silas Larson yeah ah if you fall uh
pull at Meghan Markle do it for a moving
fan no because then I'll get covered in
it mate exactly thanks Alice appreciate
the two horrible image needs okay
what movie of recent years you recommend
to watch is there any hope for Hollywood
I don't know how recent they are the
last two movies I watched and really
liked are the accountant with Ben
Affleck insert your own joke yeah it's
actually about it's not about the
oppressed minority you're thinking
obviously yeah it's not about the Jews
yeah it's about
um an autistic man oh really yeah who's
like a like a a very highly skilled
killer as well okay and the other one is
Cloud Atlas neither of these are
particularly recent but these are two
brilliant movies it depends what you
classify as racing because you can
classify like 10 films from 10 20 years
ago as recent movies so I mean those two
are yeah so in which case I mean what is
the most
yeah
actually yes well done king of Staten
Island it's now off Netflix well done
it's uh We've we wanted to interview him
pick something or other I'm getting I'm
such an old man comedian who has sex
with all attractive women and people
don't know why I know who you mean yeah
what's his face yeah well anyway he did
the king of Staten Island it's
absolutely brilliant
Bill Burr is in it and um Steve Buscemi
one of my all-time favorites are correct
yeah he's incredible and it's a
beautiful heartwarming film all of us
Pete Davidson all about the importance
of fathers and fatherhood it's wonderful
hi and thank you very much I really
appreciate that uh King Talbot with the
two quid thank you so much for that I
appreciate it
uh Darius Hutchinson congratulations on
400 000 subscribers guys uh best podcast
on YouTube thanks for the repost FF will
you ever move totally to locals I don't
think so no uh I don't think so but we
we'll keep we'll keep it all under
review Darius uh at the moment we just
want to keep putting out the great
content for you guys on YouTube we're
doing two interviews a week we're
putting three raws out a week we're
doing clips and various things Francis
is doing his comedy sketches I've got my
own stuff going on as well uh so
there'll be plenty of content on YouTube
uh don't go anywhere yeah exactly thank
you you very much uh Andy Benton with a
five dollars oh my God I sent KK's
Oxford Union debate to every Progressive
I know I now have no friends I hope you
guys can talk to Jonathan Hyde this year
thanks for making my work days less
boring all right mate we've uh let's get
some Indian Flags in the chat because me
here has sent 50 Quid get the
Indianapolis yes she's an Indian accent
please Indian accent please what did he
say Indian accent please congrats on the
400 cake guys so well deserved been a
while but how to shout out this
Milestone and the Oxford Union speech I
love you guys thank you very much thank
you very much mate do you know we've got
a [ __ ] ton of fans in India we do mate
unfortunately it's a massive country so
we're not going to go and visit there
and do a show
some a couple of people have messaged me
going come and play Bangalore I'm like
no
why not because there's about four
people that who like trigonometry in
Bangalore
how do you know
oh it's probably about 50 20. I don't
know mate it's the biggest
English-speaking market in terms of
numerically in terms of number of people
in the world
right
now I don't have any money no well
actually that's except me here yeah it
was just Center load yeah 50 Quid guys
where are the Indian Flags let's get
more Indian Flags in the chat anytime
someone sends us over 50.50 pounds uh it
was 50 Swiss Francs or whatever we uh
give them a special shout out so let's
get some Indian Flags in the chat for me
here thank you very much for that and
keep going lovely
uh Brendan O'Leary oh yes him and
everything everywhere odd at once he's
not even Irish man I know he's not
cheers Brendan appreciate the tenor uh
she's this is a Martin V or Martin Ray
Martin Ray with the 20 chips says
congrats guys with the wef trending we
need a Swiss Accent on trigonometry but
please knock Klaus Schwab do you know
what for class swab you just do an Arty
accent
what what will you be you will have
nothing and you will be happy and so
will say you wouldn't yes wait
foreign
he looks like a Nazi he sounds like a
Nazi and allegedly he's got some kind of
great plot to take over the world
however they are unsubstantiated claims
and he's a very wealthy and powerful man
yeah class Rob we're not saying you're a
Nazi we're not saying you're not a Nazi
we don't know we're just saying you look
like one and sound like one exactly and
behave like one sort of like a pedo baby
Nazi
pedo baby what the [ __ ] is a peach
surely a baby cannot be a pedo because
he would be having sex with people its
own age well let's have a look let's
have a look tell me you don't have tell
me you haven't prepared the story about
keto baby it's not I don't want to see
this right let's get a picture of cloud
Schwab it's going to have a peach of
cloud Schwab and let's discuss do you
know what I haven't looked into the
cloud Schwab we everything because I'll
be honest with you I don't want to
I mean it does not look like a nice man
does it no he doesn't
and his face is melting into his neck
yeah
yeah
have you actually looked into this Cloud
Schwab thing no we've got Michael
schellenberger coming on soon we can
talk to him about it yeah oh I I don't
they're gonna make me believe all this
conspiracy [ __ ] that's why I don't go
[ __ ] near it
I don't want it
I Don't Go Near it because I know I'm
going to end up believing it
he saw when we did that brilliant
interview with um Mickey the Sherma and
we're talking about conspiracy theories
and he went ah you know and and I don't
what do you think about um we haven't
released that yet no no it's brilliant
and we talk all about Epstein in it not
Alex aspirin Jeffrey right
and I'm like you can [ __ ] kill
himself
nothing will persuade me that that man
did not
anyway we will see we'll see next Anton
uh r r tnz well if I have kiwi dollars
mate oh cheers from New Zealand enjoy
your approach to controversial issues
don't always agree but appreciate
rational thought and humor effectively
combined thank you very much for that
appreciate it no it's not it Anton
because we had uh uh a kill Brian
do you not see that he's been a member
for 29 months and he says can you pull
it up or should I read it off you can't
uh highlights just an update the head of
science bigots has now become an
assistant head bigger they don't know
what they're in for congratulations on
the promotion to kill Brian the head of
science figure has now become an
assistant head bigoted well mate smash
them yeah not literally though because
they're children exactly that is against
the law so it is you could end up like
Francis you're not presenting a YouTube
a YouTube show
or being a stand-up comedian with a
criminal record exactly
and Scott sent us 50 pieces here's your
50 can I get a shout out no mate get
[ __ ] get [ __ ] I know up up north
where you live that's a lot of money not
down here all to the financially
illiterate exactly
next that's it that's it okay well let's
do a story about a great man
no this is an even better man I know
this is an even better man this is it
Kevin Spacey given Life Time achievement
I wouldn't hey
your great actor especially in bedroom
this is a nation that knows what he's
doing he knows Talent when it [ __ ]
sees Pizza
there we go by the way Laura smart has
got a conspiracy theory he's not
actually a nunt really yeah she says
he's innocent of all charges
she did a video on her YouTube channel
and her YouTube channel is tanked since
did she really do a video see brilliant
Laura did a video so her her channel is
called unfathomable crimes yeah or crime
and she did a video basically defending
Kevin Spacey brilliant and she her
channel has just gone through the floor
as a result so go and check it out by
the way Laura is great she's a huge
supporter of the show and she's got a
it's great for the bird she talks all
about like missing people on that yeah
who've been you know birds have been
missing or whatever and uh yeah but she
decided to go out there on a limb yeah
and the limp smashed her in the face
why what what was her argument that he's
innocent of all charges I don't know
Anton said he's just gay all right it's
good all right anyway let's find out
where he got a lifetime award in Italy
that's what we want uh Tino's Wasteland
said what is her Channel's name it's
unfathomable unfathomable crime actor
Kevin Spacey has received a Lifetime
Achievement Award in Italy his Awards
comes days after he appeared in a UK
Court to face seven charges of sexual
assault against a man in the early
naughties the timing is better Factor
the Museum of Cinema in Turin said it
handed the prize in recognition of Mr
Spacey's personal aesthetic and
authorial contribution to the developers
mate you go through the Arts and come on
oh I'm sorry a person
an authority of authorial contribution
to the development of the art of drama
he thanked the museum for having the
balls to present him with the award
Mr Spacey I mean that's an unfortunate
term to use if you've got seven charges
sexual assault levied against you anyway
Mr space he won the Oscars uh for
performances in American Beauty great
movie the usual suspect brilliant movie
but it's barely worked since being
unfairly accused of sexual misconduct he
did not directly address the allegations
at the ceremony but delivered a speech
saying he was surely blessed grateful
humbled and very horny my heart is very
full tonight towards him as is my penis
yeah towards the Museum of Cinema for
having had lapel to invite me tonight he
said the 63 year old's appearance at
Southern
uh the 63 year old's appearance at
Southern Crown Court in London on Friday
was via video link for the plea and
trial preparation hearing the offenses
are alleged to have taken place between
2001 and 2005. the oscar-winning actor
is now facing a total of 12 sexual
offenses in the UK against four men in
July he denied five allegations relating
to three men who are now in their 30s or
40s when he appeared at London's Old Bay
Lake they were not kids they were adult
men and their gays don't have consent
huh didn't he get accused by by a man
who said that he molested him when he
was underage I think I'm not I don't
follow it that closely I just see the
headline I know probably announced it
looks like announce sounds like a
nonsense he's a bit weird gotta be a
nonsense
by the way Kevin I know you've got
powerful lawyers mate we're just kidding
around I don't know if you're a nons
maybe you're innocent I mean his hands
are pretty full at the moment because
he's molesting someone
Francis yeah has poop and your
girlfriend ever talked to you about
starting gently
about warming things up about easing in
about sophistication and being a little
bit you know delicate no not just
ramming the most offensive thing you can
down the throat of the audience has she
ever talk to you about this no she
should do mate she may get more
satisfaction
huh
anyway [ __ ] you
Super Chat please Anton
let's say right lady sarcastic hey the
WF has its own YouTube channel no
conspiracy you can hear it all in their
own words we're gonna have to [ __ ]
talk I don't want to I don't want you
dude all right lady thank you very much
we'll check it out
hey tram with a five dollars
thank you from a new subscriber hey Tim
thank you very much and welcome home
first time here I do not know why I'm
talking like this why are you doing an
Italian accent from someone who's from
Scandinavia I don't know okay so how do
they speak in Spanish Let Go of the Hat
it won't fall off it will do because
it's such reckon the Vikings just walked
around like this they just fought
battles going yeah
yeah exactly anyway uh so yeah first
time here and I'm not sure what is going
on uh just talking doing a little look
looksie and your opinions I have this
tasty sandwich so I will stay for a
while thank you Krista basically the raw
show is where we take the piss make fun
of loads of things do offensive and
ridiculous accents and talk a lot of
[ __ ] uh it's very different to the
serious interviews that we do on the
channel uh this is where we let out our
comedic and satirical instincts and have
a lot of fun and basically prepare
ourselves for our own cancellation
Krista thank you very much for the
Fiverr uh the shade the shade tree oh my
god I've trapped my head oh there's no
message so you don't need that okay put
my hat's over there so go and do it
whilst I go and get in my hat
otherwise I won't be able to do any of
the other things to carry on with the
next thing just walked offset for no
reason it's my head is over here and Sue
is the Israeli head yes well subliming
on the Jews man it's not gonna fall you
dropped your hat
that I dropped my head
appreciate it
uh fsp with the 10 says apologize for
thinking Francis was Dak Shepard first
time here who's dank Shepherd and told
us to get a picture of back Shepherd
please who the hell is that I know who
you look like
comedian it's coming no you've been
compared to a comedian you've been
insulted already yeah mate [ __ ] hell
that looks nothing like me I mean the
face is equally weird though it is weird
but that means Birds fit yeah he is so
yeah I do look like him well done thank
you
thanks
old oh my cap buy bloody gum the bloody
flat cap oh yes who do you sometimes
compare yourself to I'm beyond
comparison mate uh then I really I've
got no idea I don't really compare
myself to people
what about you Ansel who do you compare
yourself to
dank Shepherd no you don't you compare
yourself to Rapha Benitez next
oh well that's it guys keep the paypals
coming keep the super chats coming by
the way Francis let's set the likes
Target for today 1300 people watching
let's get to 650 likes in the next 15
minutes perfect we will carry on with
the show Anton we have some good news
from Twitter do we oh there's good news
from Twitter come on let's bring up the
good news from Twitter so much positive
news from the best platform in the world
of course we're joking YouTube it is
yeah it's Twitter is the best platform
Anton the Taliban are on Twitter and
they're being verified ladies and
gentlemen that's right I'll make sure
you know we've got to make sure that
they are the real and proper Taliban
Taliban start buying blue ticks on
Twitter well fantastic yeah why not Gary
there he is there's one of them tweeting
yes yes uh the Taliban have started
using Twitter's paid for verification
feature meaning some now have blue ticks
in their account previously the book
tick Blue Tick indicated active notable
and authentic accounts of public
interest no previously it indicated
anyone who was prominent and left wing
and denied anyone who was not left wing
a [ __ ] tick anyway and could not be
purchased but now users can buy them
through the new Twitter blue service at
least two ton of band officials and four
prominent supporters in Afghanistan are
currently using the check marks Hedy
atolla hediat the head of the taliban's
department for access to information uh
now has a tick his account has 187 000
followers so nearly as much as me and he
regularly posts information related to
the telephone Administration he had his
paid for Blue Tick removed last month
according to local media but it is now
returned in a victory of free fish Free
Speech Abdul haq Hamad head of the media
a watchdog at the Afghan Ministry of
information and culture also has a blue
tick on his account that has a hundred
and seventy thousand followers prominent
Taliban supporters have acquired the
Blue Tick too including Jeremy corbyn
Mohammed Jalal who previously identified
as a Taliban official praised the new
owner of Twitter on Monday declaring
that Elon Musk was making Twitter great
again evidence the presence of the
Hardline islamists on Twitter has been a
topic of conversation or controversy for
some time in October 2021 uh U.S former
U.S president a well-known Hardline
islamist Donald Trump exactly he was
suspended from the platform after his
supporters stormed the U.S Capitol said
we live in a world with the Taliban is a
huge presence on Twitter did your
favorite American president has been
silenced this is unacceptable the
Twitter blue service was introduced in
December it cost eight dollars a month
and an increased fee of eleven dollars
is paid by those using the Twitter app
on Apple devices subscribers to Twitter
blue benefit from Priority ranking and
research mentions and replies to help
fight spam and Bot according to the
platform before the introduction of
Twitter blue none of the observed
accounts for Taliban officials carried
the blue tick mark That Was Then used to
indicate the identities of users
verified by Twitter after the return to
power and Kabul in August 2021 the group
took over verified accounts run by the
previous administration including the
Afghan Cricket Board the sporting bodies
account now carries a gold tick is put a
gold tick I don't know all right under
Twitter's new policies gold check marks
indicate business businesses while
Graves ones are for other users such as
governing authorities you should
introduce a black one with a little
crescent in it just for islamists
exactly just so you know who they are I
mean to be fair with islamists they do
tell you pretty quickly Taliban
officials and supporters are prolific
users of Twitter using the platform to
disseminate key messages staying home
exactly see the Taliban just they're
just like our health care System yeah
yep they want you to stay home and put
to save lives and save lives if you're a
woman yeah all right Jennifer with the
tennis says no stay clear of the WF
stuff so depressing congrats on the 400k
thank you for the tenor Jennifer and we
also have a paypalio from I'll fight you
naked who I believe is Scottish Scottish
France is up with Mexican food reaming
out the night before uh
before Meghan Markle comes to town and
use him as a and no I'm not going to do
the rest of that mate that is pure
unadulterated filth disgusting yeah I
mean he's Scottish so he probably reads
that as to his kid there's a bedtime
story yeah
next uh fsp with a 10. this one we've
done
all right
no it wasn't yeah it was it was about
you looking like that no no but it was
apologized oh was it sorry apologize for
thinking for instance was Dax Shepard
first time here all right thanks fsp I
appreciate it uh the real alternator
with the term dollar says thank you both
for being a voice of fun and reasoning
these times and for helping expose us to
so many fantastic and harmful harmful
rather opinions real horsinator thank
you very much for the ten dollars
uh Minecraft for two quid Oxford KK
making Oxford call again you bet I am
thank you Minecraft Andy Benton where
the two dollars says any chance of
getting Matt T be on the show we are
working on it as we speak thank you very
much for that Andy uh the shade tree all
right the shade tree intellectual you
guys are doing great it would be
brilliant if you two could focus on
men's mental health male suicide is a
significant problem and we need more
access and destigmatization thank you
fellas what did uh the shade tree
intellectual did you watch our interview
with Ricky the grannon which is the last
interview we released Richard granan one
of our favorite guests and that is
actually I mean we didn't sit down and
go let's talk about male mental health
but actually when we talked about how to
live a happy life I think we were coming
at it from a fairly male perspective
because despite appearances we identify
as male exactly for the moment for the
moment I mean Francis is halfway through
transitioning which is why more man than
most most people in this [ __ ] place
that's
questionable but anyway uh we talked a
lot about actually how to you know how
to live a happy life I think especially
for a man
um and
um a lot of it is
in that interview uh the interview is
not entirely about that but it's it's a
[ __ ] great interview it is a great go
check that out but I I hear you that's
definitely a subject that we should
remember to continue talking about
uh John we were 999 Massey
congratulations for getting over 400 000
subscribers everyone tell your friends
and family let's get our favorite show
to over 1 million Subs Francis do you
know that if every single if people who
watch the show subscribe to it if
everyone who watches it subscribe to it
we would be on a million subscribers
right now why are you not subscribing
they're terrified exactly
and then my girlfriend sees and then
she'll leave me because she's a work
idiot or get a real girlfriend and
there's not a lot of them yeah right
you'd be gay and you've got to check
before you've got loads of problematic
gaze right exactly I mean look Francis
we've discussed this many a time if it
wasn't for the fact that you have to
have sex with a man I would love to be
gay it's just easier
right they seem happier that's why
they're called gay yeah they say you
know you just you know what you go down
on you oh he goes down and then you just
watch a football yeah it's all done
teaching is considered a normal part of
the relationship exactly it's fine
foreign
for lunch on a Sunday look still love
you yeah I just needed you know to bust
a nut exactly I'd love to be gay mate
yeah an old head clearer you know
it's clear
do you know one of my friends who shall
remain nameless she told me that uh she
works in a very prestigious Place uh
though she had a colleague who was a
very intelligent man who was gay and
like like once a week or twice a week
like I think it's got on top of him at
work he'd be say to a right I'm off I'm
just she should be like where you're
going it's like yeah I'm just going to
go and get laid and then I'll be back in
about 40.
being a man is great especially if you
can have sex with other men I just I I
can't do I don't understand how women do
it to be honest yeah you've got some
sweaty hairy thing on top of you exactly
that hasn't washed
come on
[Laughter]
laughs
[Laughter]
it's a Pity we're not advertising my
Escape tonight yes that would have been
beautiful
if it transitions from big and lovely to
mild fat phobia
thank you Silas
laughs
John Harris Let's get some American
flags let's get some Freedom let's get
some oh he's in the same Highlands all
right whatever okay let's take all that
back let's get some money laundering in
the chat for the wonderful John Harris
with the 50 says I'm pretty sure you
don't have a Cayman Islands hat we don't
we don't we love a bit of money
laundering yep right in the chat in my
jeans all right let's put some of that
in the chat thank you very much for that
that's it okay not it Francis or maybe
it is it or maybe it is it well Francis
do you know who yes who would never
engage in any money laundry yeah it's
expressvpn everybody Express VPN is the
only VPN that we advertise at
trigonometry and not just because they
told us that if we did advertise they
would pull their funding hey expressvpn
is the best VPN out there they have an
incredible deal whereby if you purchase
a 12-month deal with expressvpn you get
an extra three months free so that's 15
months for the price of 12 three months
free when you purchase a 12 month deal
when you go to
www.expressvpn.com forward slash trigger
check them out indeed uh guys keep the
super chats and the paypals coming
giving us things to bounce off but
Francis should we talk about another
great man yeah let's talk about literary
genius yes let's talk about it it's
Story number 13 Anton I mean this is a a
book that has changed the world good
what book is it mate let's see
oh [ __ ] sake
and Prince Harry spare he's not even a
prince
is it didn't he didn't he abandon his
royal title I thought he kept them what
do you mean he said he's leaving the
royal family to concentrate on being a
Minge no but he kept I said I don't care
how is he still a prince I don't think
he renounced his titles what do you mean
I think they kept told of their titles
they're still officially the Duke and
Duchess or something they don't even
live in the same country as Sussex yet
they kept their [ __ ] exactly you want
to go to America right what are the
people of Sussex gonna think exactly
well then they don't think to be honest
with you they're actually their title is
very appropriate when you consider how
woke they are and how woke Sussex is
Sussex is pretty much the workers County
in the UK yeah that's why I said they
don't think yeah
boom
first week of the controversial Memoir
sales breaks official UK records reports
Nielsen Guinness World Records and
mortar that is [ __ ] depressing man uh
Prince Harry spare has sold almost uh
let's see uh Anton's had enough half a
million copies in the UK in his first
week on sale making it the fastest
selling non-fiction book since records
began according to Nielsen spare sold a
total of 467
000 print copies for UK retailers in the
first week of release making it number
one on the book charts it does not
include ebook sales or audiobook copies
penguin Random House UK said the book
had sold three quarters of a million
copies in the UK across all formats odd
books your ebooks and audio books in its
first week of these 400
000 copies were on its first day on sale
in the UK Larry Finley managing director
of Transworld that's a bit transphobic
the prrh division which published the
book in the UK so Guinness World Records
had confirmed that spare was fast the
faster selling non-fiction book ever on
his first day of publication Finley said
as well as being the fastest selling we
now know that it is also
the biggest biggest selling Memoir ever
in its first week of publication uh and
in second place in this week's UK chart
is Board of lunch they're healthy slow
cooker book by Nathan Anthony which sold
around 32 000 copies
spare is the fastest selling non-fiction
book in the UK since Neil book data's
official printed book sales records
began in 1998. the previous record was
held by the first pinch of Nom cookbook
by K Allison which sold
210 506 copies in his first three days
of release in 2019. Waterstone said
pre-orders for spare which are counted
in the first official week of sales were
the largest on record for a non-fiction
title for the retailer with non-fiction
category manager John Cottrell saying we
are [ __ ] cream
Waterstone sales of spare have been
exceptional cultural said seven days
after publication spare is one of
waterstone's fastest selling books in a
decade the book also remains number one
on the Amazon bestseller shot and is the
site's best-selling non-fiction title
spare so they combine 1.4 million copies
on its first day on sale in the US
Canada and the UK according to the books
publisher penguin Random House
overtaking Barack Obama as a Promised
Land which had previously recorded the
big spur the biggest First Day sales for
the publisher the US had originally
printed two million copies and the
publisher is now reprinting
carries controversial Memoir spare made
headlines of publication the guided by
all the rest of it so there you go mate
turns out if you throw your family under
the bus you get dollars as a result of
it I I mean you could try me but I don't
think you're throwing a mum under the
bus is going to get you 15 million
pounds in advance that might get a few
thousand views on Twitter yeah that was
worth it no
anyway yeah Francis let's find out if we
have the likes Oh indeed we do we have
the likes we need to carry on with the
show for another half an hour so keep
the messages coming in giving us things
to respond to uh Anton what what have we
got let's see uh Jack how to cook Jordan
Pearson with a jack Canadian dollars
don't have a pair but here's 20 bucks
thanks Jack
that is it fantastic there we go sorry
I've just got distracted I just got
booked for a pretty big show in America
tomorrow night uh keep an eye out on
that cool so uh shall we look at some
quality content with the BBC used to do
okay yeah let's go and say Anton this is
the bottom pinching this is what the BBC
used to do back when it was great have a
watch of this
excuse me sir how do you feel about
women pinching men's Bottoms in the
streets
foreign
so how do you feel about ladies picking
picking three pardon how do you feel
about ladies picking gentlemen up in the
streets well I always do myself
oh I see you do you think it's a nice
idea if ladies molest gentleman in the
streets instead of the other way around
it's refreshing if nothing else
how do you feel about Beauty quality of
the Sexes do what complete equality of
the Sexes no
[Music]
foreign
did you like that
good God you found the knife at me
I mean I just pinched up awesome now do
you think that's wrong
I do you
yes it's Bad Manners
excuse me how do you feel about women
pinching men's bushings in the street I
don't know
no that was a bit of a shock actually
thank you
that's what
how do you feel about women picking men
up in the streets after all you do it
all the time no you don't actually the
good old days the good old dead woman
and you could handle a bit of pinching
exactly you did that now you get
arrested yeah you you would sexual
assault mate mate
if if
they're arrested no
but there'll be some welcome inch that
would yeah I mean I mean I was
traumatized by this attractive woman my
mouth detaching my bottom
that is true that wouldn't touch my
bottom anytime love exactly darling I
mean no I'm married sorry take that back
yeah but that was when the BBC produced
quality content
there we go political correctness gone
mad exactly in it mate all right next
okay so uh New Zealand Dollars mate well
uh
rtnz while spare cereals indicate
depressingly low tasting the British
public at least it means that a lot of
people can still read silver lining
least of all Harry thanks RIT NZ and uh
Glenn with the Fiverr says I got my 600
Quid cost of living payment from the
government today have a Fiverr right if
something doesn't add up in there yeah
you've got 600 Quid from a government
and you gave us five yeah we invested in
an entrepreneur yeah that's what we are
entrepreneurs yeah mate that's what we
are what that Chinese today was an
investment was it it was a [ __ ]
investment brilliant investment Glenn
thank you very much for the five I'm
much appreciated Lorna's little loves
with the three quid thank you so much
for that thank you Lorna hey
FF would love to hear your thoughts on
the teacher's strike if you haven't
already covered it up okay we can talk
about that once we have done this
supercharge Anton I have a story in the
chat about the teacher Striker hey
how much have you ever missed doing
stand-up comedy as in pre-book PC era
luckily here in Israel we are 10 to 15
years behind on that regard
yeah exactly just like us yeah yeah so
it'd be what 2007 you're more than
welcome
uh do you miss doing comedy do you know
when I started when I first started
comedy in 2009 like it was just all
right jokes
genuinely that's what it was
and like if you didn't have a rape joke
and you said there was something wrong
with you just look down on you like
what's wrong with you it's just sorry oh
yeah
this is the thing some of the evolution
of Comedy is not a bad thing yeah right
people just people no longer doing cheap
[ __ ] that is only offensive and not
clever or not interesting in any way I
I'm glad people aren't doing that I
don't think people should be canceled
for that I think people should just you
know it's good that people don't laugh
at that sort of [ __ ] anymore I do
genuinely
um so I don't miss that but I just think
people should still be allowed to play
with things
um and so it's a complicated ones in
some ways as we talked about right at
the start like Rogan says this is the
best time for comedy in many ways of
course People Like Us who want to push
back against whatever's going on yeah
you know uh but do we did we want to
talk about the teacher strike yeah yeah
as long as we'll cry through is that the
law Super Chat we've got okay so do you
want to do it or shall I you'll do it
okay I'll do it WF Klaus this declares
the polycar it's it's incomplete I've
got no idea what any of that means I'm
sure it might be a very clever joke
Silas but it's gone way over my head
mate there's a surprise let's talk about
the teacher strikes and mate teachers
because you used to be a teacher I did
used to be a teacher indeed teachers
vote to strike for seven days in
February and March wave of action to
start next month as an education
secretary accuses Union of failing
children
there we go
millions of pupils face further
disruption to their learning after the
large teacher Union voted in favor of
strike action uh the education secretary
Chilean Keegan accused teachers of
turning their backs on children after 90
percent of those who voted in the Neu or
the National Education Union ballot but
it's a walkout the union voted to strike
on a turnout of 53 only uh 53 percent
only narrowly meeting the legal
threshold and the first strike will take
place on Wednesday February 1st
it could affect up to 23 400 schools
across England and Wales with teachers
walking out for four days in each region
staggered across February and March
education strikes are a particular
concern for the government due to the
knock on economic impact of parents
staying home from work to care for their
children the NAU is asking for a pay
rise in line with inflation fully funded
by the government the current pay deal
for teachers this year is for a
staggered pay rise starting at 8.9
percent for the newly qualified teachers
and tapering down to five percent for
the most experienced the majority of
teachers will receive five percent
however unions are concerned that the
rise is not fully funded by the
government meaning it will have to come
in part from school budgets that are
already heavily stretched by the cost of
living crisis Keegan said that the
department had already met the Union's
request for an additional 2 billion in
schools funding and that spending on
schools was at highest level or its
highest level in history she will meet
education unions for talks on Wednesday
after discussions last week failed to
resolve the dispute any school closures
or disruption to teaching or fuel fears
that children may slip further behind
academically and developmentally in the
wake of the pandemic just pause here for
a second you know how like the work
generation are completely [ __ ] yeah
these kids are going to be even worse
but Mike how do I add two plus two
climate change
uh the reality is
um if you go into from
Primary School to secondary school and
you are at academically behind your
peers you will never catch up right so
that means they are going to be stupid
well what you what we're producing with
this generation is they're going to be
significantly inferior academically
illiterate innumerate
that's just a top set maps group mate so
so what do you think about the strikes
mate five percent well I don't think
they should be striking I don't I really
don't know that it should be striking I
think at the moment things particularly
with the pandemic particularly with
the terrible terrible deal that was
given to our children during the
pandemic where they didn't go to school
for months on end we're not talking when
we're not being honest about a whole
host of subjects of issues that concern
education number one the fact is that
there is a whole house I don't know how
many but it's it's something like a
hundred thousand children or maybe
slightly less around that figure have
just simply dropped from the alert from
the uh from the register we don't know
where they are they have simply
disappeared from education completely so
we've got tens of thousands of children
who've disappeared from education what
we have is uh vulnerable children who
during the pandemic were at home when
they desperately needed to be cared for
by uh teachers and staff at school
they had it even worse they're now their
their their education is now being
impacted and what has happened as well
during the pandemic is working class
kids and middle class kids there's
always a gap with educational attainment
but that Gap has now widened because
during the pandemic people could afford
online tutors parents were at home
looking making sure the kids were online
learning whereas a lot of working class
kids where they come from single parent
backgrounds those jobs they didn't stop
parents still had to go out and work
which meant the kid was left to its own
devices at home which meant that no work
was being done
so that is my take so your point is
working class kids are lazy exactly
all right well
I won't actually have a massive opinion
on it other other than I'm tired of
people striking when they get in Pay
Rises when most of the country's not
getting any pay Rises at all
yep I mean some people like they need
more money
but I don't think everybody needs more
money I mean not everybody yeah but most
people Carl Schwab doesn't need more
money no it doesn't you need your soul
I am feasting on this side you will be
inside me and you will be happy yes yeah
okay he does actually look like he feeds
on people he's looking the way he looks
and the way he sounds sounds like he he
just comes across as someone who feeds
on human souls he does and I mean if you
allegedly allegedly if you found out
that there he had this mystical tropical
island where they all went right to feed
on children Souls you'll be like
if that makes sense does indeed Francis
uh oh we got some super chats let's read
them out guys keep them coming super
chattios oh oh it's Simon say oh oh what
someone put the Hut wrong way oh let me
get special tiny hunt says good you'll
see the vice feminism should bring on
Sydney Watson and Paul Davis only saying
voices on panel zubi has been on post
show uh actually Sydney Watson I think
is up for coming on the show should we
get her on yeah let's go Sydney on Anton
would you make a note send a Harmon a
message and just tell him to book her
please well where is she both Sidney uh
she's an American now from Australia
she's from Australia I'll watch that
Dubai mate he was [ __ ] mental was it
yeah what happened oh my she's Birds
kicking off just sign mental [ __ ] and
she was just not normal yeah oh I did
see that clip yeah she was like the
problem with woke people is they shout
everyone down and this other woman this
other woman went shut up
exactly and she was just like oh I'm
just trying to talk Yankee
anyway it didn't really show people
Laura Smiles just caught up on the show
yeah and she says she's redoing that
video cutting out the bit about Epstein
and she says truth will out space he's
innocent
I mean that is not the hill that I would
die on Laura I'm gonna be honest with
you that she's gonna die
she's a proud northerner she's a proud
northerner even though wonderful actor
and by all accounts a good man next
that's it all right Francis you had a
great clip of Aldous Huxley basically
predicting uh our world so this is a
brilliant clip this is all this oxy
author of Brave New World and here he is
Mr Huxley in your new essays you state
that these various enemies of Freedom
are pushing us toward a real life Brave
New World and you say that it's awaiting
us just around the corner
first of all can you detail for us what
life in this Brave New World which you
fear so much or what life might be like
well to start with I think this kind of
the dictatorship of the future I think
will be very unlike the dictatorships
which we've been familiar with in the
immediate first
I mean take another book prophesying The
Future which was a very remarkable book
George Orwell's 1984 but this book was
written at the height of the study in
his regime and just after the Hitler
regime and he there he foresaw a
dictatorship using entirely the methods
of Terror the methods of physical
violence
now I I think what is going to happen in
the future is the dictators will find as
the old saying goes but you can do
everything with there and it's except
sit on them but if you want to preserve
your power indefinitely you have to get
the consent of the rule and this they
will do Party by drugs as I foresaw in
in Brave New World passed it by these
new techniques of of propaganda
they will do it by bypassing the sort of
rational side of man and appealing to
his subconscious and his deeper emotions
and his physiology even
and so making him actually love his
slavery I mean I think this is the
danger that actually people may be in
some ways happy under the new regime but
they will be happy in situation where
they open to be happy but let me ask you
this you're talking about a world that
could take place within the confines of
a totalitarian state let's become more
immediate more urgent about it we
believe any way that we live in
democracy here in the United States do
you believe that this Brave New World
that you talk about
uh
could let's say in the next quarter
Century The Next Century
could come here to our Shores I think it
could I mean I I that's why I feel it's
so extremely important here and now to
start thinking about these problems not
to let ourselves be taken by surprise by
the new advances in technology I mean
the for example in in regard to the use
of the of the drugs we know there's
enough evidence now for us to be able on
the basis of this evidence and using a
certain amount of creative imagination
to foresee the kind of uses which could
be made in a by people of bad will with
these things and to attempt to to
forestall this and in the same way I
think with these other methods of
propaganda we can foresee and we can do
a good deal to forestall I mean the
price of freedom is eternal vigilance
a man ahead of his time yeah and
actually I've read Brave New World but I
don't remember her very well I have this
thing where any book I read in my young
years I just don't remember yeah uh have
you read it yeah I've read Brave New
World it's basically a society where it
was built around Hedonism and you were
you would you weren't you didn't think
because everything about life was
deriving pleasure from it so that and as
a result it's really unfamiliar yeah and
as a result you didn't you didn't
question you didn't actually think you
didn't pursue any type of intellectual
path because all that mattered was you
taking the drug soma and having physical
experiences which are pleasurable
and that is the future that Huxley
predicted and he based it on his
experiences in California in the 1920s
you know it's kind of partly what we
talked about with David Starkey today
when he talked about valuesless value
listen valuelessness yeah you know we we
are in this
um it does sometimes feel like a very
you know I remember B do you remember
when I I turned around that contract in
2018
and all these comedians started
attacking me and they all claimed that
the reason I turned it down was that
um I was trying to get attention or
whatever when I turned it down because
for me it was a matter of principle and
I and I had this thought going around in
my head at the time I realized like the
reason these people suspect me of not
being principled is that they don't have
principles and they they are the sort of
people that they just go for whatever
benefits them in the moment they don't
understand somebody who might be willing
to risk something or even sacrifice
something for something they believe in
and he was such a shock to me because I
I mean you know in the naivety that you
have you kind of go around thinking
everyone thinks the way you do sometimes
and but certainly I mean before we
started doing this I felt that way
and he was such a shock to me when these
comedians were reacting in that way
because I was like
I mean I anyone who knows me knows me
that I'm obviously not like that right
and that I stand up for what I believe
in even if it's painful in the shorts
I'm even painful in a long time you know
I just have principles but they were
acting as if it's not even conceivable
to them that somebody would put
principle or some kind of belief or idea
ahead of personal gain and personal
benefit and I see something similar in
this like this desire for for pleasure
above all is kind of the same you know
what I mean yeah it's people who who are
unprepared to uh to be interested in
something greater than just the
immediate momentary pleasure or the
immediate momentary gain and it's a it's
a very strange it's strange to me that
people are like that I find it very
weird but if you think about it it's it
makes sense particularly with the
godlessness as well the um Huxley talked
about if there is no God and if there is
no afterlife and if there is no point in
sacrificing yourself for and afterlife
where you're going to go to heaven then
why should you
withstand any amount of pain or
suffering when this is all there is
because pleasure is not fulfilling I I
don't think you need God for this at all
I disagree with this idea I know the
point you're making I'm not saying
you're wrong I'm just giving you my
opinion yeah pleasure is unfulfilling
yeah it's unsatisfying it's like trying
to fill a deep void by dropping a grain
of sand in it one at a time it just that
that whole that every human being has
inside of them does not get filled by
Pleasure it gets filled by meaning
but here's the thing it gets filled
momentarily by Pleasure I don't think it
does I think it's a substitute it's like
you go to you go to a McDonald's and you
shove a burger down you but you're not
actually fulfilled by it
oh yeah you don't feel good afterwards
not you know and I think it's the same
like that whole in in in in every human
being gets filled by meaning and purpose
right and for the way that that meaning
comes different for different people for
some people it's having children and
looking after them for other people it's
their work for other people it's their
contribution to their Community for
others it's doing something for charity
for others it's you know our or
creativity of some kind but
um it doesn't get filled by Pleasure and
surely by the time you get to I don't
know your 30s you you know you've
noticed that surely there is no meal
there is no amount of alcohol or drugs
or whatever that can fill that void
meaningfully look I completely agree
with you and I think you know for the
for the vast majority of people
I look I I just think that there's a lot
of people who don't think that deeply
about these issues who uh many in many
ways are trapped in a treadmill uh who
are making the same mistake again and
again and again uh who are deeply
frustrated who used alcohol and a
variety of other of other things in
order to
ameliorate the pain in order to provide
a brief escape from the misery of their
existence and they just do that hamster
wheel
you see it all the time you know well I
remember when I was I remember one of
the first jobs I had when I left
University it was a terrible job in a
call center and people were going like
and it was Wednesday or Thursday and I
remember just being there going this is
absolutely horrendous and everyone's oh
don't worry about it Francis should be
Friday we'll be down the pub
you know well that's not really solving
the problem no but you've got to think
as well you look at our society our
society is entirely built around
pressure you know and this idea that if
you consume you will be fulfilled
that's what a consumerist society that
gives you that illusion the thing is I
don't have any problem with consuming
things you know I just I don't think
that is the answer to the fundamental
question that every human being carries
within themselves no and is looking for
the answer to and I think every I I look
I am convinced that every human being is
looking for it
but I don't think anyone is Happy truly
like I don't mean I people confuse not
being unhappy with being happy they're
different things right there are people
who are quite capable of not being
unhappy by going to a job they're not
particularly enthused about uh having
their family going to the pub on a
Friday night with their mates and
whatever you can be not unhappy but to
be truly truly happy you have to have
things in your life that give you great
purpose and great meaning and I believe
every person is is looking for that at
some level yes and I I believe I mean
you say that people aren't aware I don't
think they are I don't think that's true
I think if you've got that person
one-on-one he actually talked to them
when they were not in their social mode
acting out a particular role at work or
whatever you'd find that actually
everyone has that question within them
and yeah you're right A lot of people
stop looking for answers at different
points but I think
you know there's nothing wrong with
consumption what what's wrong is
not understanding that that is and only
an answer to certain things yes like I
you like nice food I like nice food some
people like nice cars or nice clothes
they're all great right every time I've
got a better car than the one I had
before I've always been like this is
[ __ ] incredible yeah you know it's
it's not that consumption in and of
itself is bad it just doesn't fill that
void inside you and I think people need
to talk about that more you know and
this is why you know Jordan Peterson
blew up in the way that he did because
he talked particularly to men but to
everybody about the fact that
meaning and purpose comes from being a
contribution to others it comes from
taking responsibility it comes from
taking charge of your life right and I
think that's got to be a big part of the
message going forward yeah I look I I
completely agree with you I just sadly
think I don't
I I think a lot of I think a big part of
the problem is is that a lot of people
give up
I think a lot of people give up I think
it's a really sad thing to acknowledge
and it's a really sad thing to
talkable not sad to talk about to but to
witness but you see so many people how
many people have you worked with who
have given up
that that Quest that search for meaning
that search for purpose who go well this
is my lot in life and this is what it is
and I will just well but see to me the
answer to that is look around I mean we
had almost every member of our team in
the studio today yeah how many of them
have given up
look I I'm not saying yeah right so
we've created something here that gives
us meaning yeah that gives us staff
meaning that gives a lot of people
watching meaning yeah right and I think
that's the answer for a lot of people
you know is to to get involved in
something that you actually believe in
that gives you purpose that you think is
important you know and then you want you
know then you don't think that other
people are doing things when they're
doing things on a matter of principle
because they're trying to gain something
because you are a personal Principle as
well I think I think that what it comes
down to is uh because Anton has given up
yeah of course yeah she's given up every
time we have these conversations I think
what it comes down
at its most basic and fundamental
fundament if you are absolutely
authentic with yourself and you are
honest with yourself and you are honest
with the people around you then you are
going to live a life that is more
authentic and as a result of that you
are going to live a life where you are
more fulfilled because you're going to
be honest about your wants your desires
your needs and what you require from
people I think in authenticity and
people who deny their true self and
people who push their true self down
whatever it is are fundamentally
miserable they are they just are and
then that's then what happens is that
they become miserable they become angry
and as a result you look to things to
escape whether it be consumerism sex
alcohol food whatever that is great
things all great things uh but and it
doesn't solve the problem no I think it
was Gabel Mata who defined addiction as
uh do doing uh things or activities or
taking substances
in a compulsive manner to try and change
what is inside you and it just ain't
gonna work the only thing that the only
thing that's going to change what's
inside you is you and that's it
unfortunately I think I suppose your
argument as well about religion is
it's a shortcut yeah it's it it's a
shortcut to connecting with that part of
you and when people used to you know do
do religion seriously in the west you'd
go to church and that's where you'd get
that yeah and then you could go back to
your shitty job yeah and you'd still
have that connection with something more
Supreme yeah and you'd also have a
deeper connection with the people around
you you'd have a deeper connection with
your community you'd you wouldn't we
wouldn't be so atomized you would have a
you know the parish the church
there's a social events around the
church
it gave meaning and purpose and
Community which is something human
beings crave
and anyway Peter banter exactly
so there we go
uh when a person can't find a deep sense
of meaning they distract themselves with
pleasure
Victor Frankel yep and Laura smart and
the chats thank you for all the bigots
who have sub to your channel to her
channel uh good stuff Laura I'm
subscribed I enjoy some of your videos
well I'm not a bird right and it's
obviously bird friendly yeah it's all
about who's gone missing and that uh but
yeah uh good to see people subscribing
to your channel fantastic meaningful
conversation none of you big had sent
any super chats or paypals we've got one
have we we've got a few all right all
right I'll stop having a garden then oh
it's Silas Larson yeah uh polycrisis
means multiple parallel crisises they
relabel upper lab overlapping challenges
as a permanent crisis that recover
requires more government monitoring and
regulation of people's everyday lives
this is a libertarian's nightmare uh
yeah it's great Point sir let's read
Thomas seoul's conflict of Visions he
talks about how crisis never goes away
and why that's the case uh and me here
uh uh Francis kept the Indian hat I am
going to get in here
Jesus you forgot to ask how come you
didn't correct the Oxford men to
mispronounce your name at the start also
how did you decide on climate change
instead of instead of other issues like
over focus on Race trans political
correctness Etc I didn't correct them
because I didn't give a [ __ ] if people
mispronounce my name and
um in terms of why did I focus on
climate change I I didn't want to rehash
the same usual cultural talking points
and I also didn't want to go out there
and do a speech that everyone who
already agrees with me would clap along
and love and everyone who disagrees with
me uh would hate I wanted to go out
there and try and persuade people
actually persuade people and you know
there was a girl who came up to me in
the bar because there was a long story
short big delay blah blah and she she
could she said to me so you think
they're awoke people in the UK
and we had a one-on-one conversation I'm
not saying I changed the Mind overnight
but I could see that I'd made an impact
with her and after my speech she came up
to me and asked for a selfie right this
is a person who thought there was no
wokeness in the UK at all
um so I wanted to challenge those kids
to think better and to be better and I
think the best way to do that is to
speak to what someone cares about or
they think they care about it you're not
going to persuade people by appealing to
things that they don't give a [ __ ] about
right and if someone's persuaded the
Free Speech uh is a right-wing bigotry
talking point you're not going to turn
them around on that the best way to
approach it is to go what do you care
about and then explain how wokeness
isn't going to achieve that and I think
the main message for me of the speech
isn't really about wokeness it's about
the overall broader attitude which is
that the solution to problems is to
whine and complain when it's just not
yeah it's just not that's not even what
achieved the technological and cultural
breakthroughs of the last uh Century you
know people think feminism uh
emancipated women that's not what
happened what happened is you get the
sexual Revolution with the invention of
the pill you get uh Automation in the in
the household which means women are no
longer required to essentially spend the
whole day cooking and cleaning or
whatever because I mean they are they
should be but they're not right they
don't have to anymore unfortunately but
I should yeah we don't agree with it
obviously all right and that's what
feminism then goes and basically makes
into a reality and the first world war
and the first world war so uh you know
technology is the answer building and
creating things as an answer to whatever
problems you envisage it's not whining
and complaining and that's the point I
wanted to make all right Anton let's go
uh sazerick with a 10 pound I bought and
readying Prince Harry's Memoir to at
least give him a chance to tell his
truth in his own words but my family is
slated me for giving him a penny of my
own cash was that wrong of me no if you
want to buy and read his Memoir you know
so you've got a more informed opinion on
Harry and Megan then you do you my
brother
uh Brendan O'Leary oh yes in BMW A Brave
New World Society is split into the Eloy
in the morologues I don't know that's
not I work from home classes uh the work
from home classes and versus the Amazon
drivers are Brendan O'Leary if that's
not the Eloy in the morologues is in H.T
wellness's time machine not Brave New
World
uh yes see
if you think the worst speaks from the
far right and left and combine them to a
single regime what would it look like
I don't even want to think about that
home thanks mate
uh Anonymous for the five dollars says
David got David Goggins would be a great
guest to get on to discuss obtaining
goals in the obsession with short-term
pleasure and avoiding responsibility
well let's get them on then yeah thank
you very much just been on Chris
Williamson's yes and John with the two
quit says France is saying desire does
things to me desire
lovely sexy Darius with the two quid
says choose one jbp as Canadian PM or
Rogan as U.S president well I think jbp
yeah
and Mariah Brooks with the twenty
dollars Mariah thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for being with us we have got a cracking
interview with joram hazoni for you
tomorrow and the Starks that on Sunday
there will be no Raw on Thursday uh
there will be raw Friday and Saturday so
we will see you tomorrow for your
amazoni and then back on Friday with
another brilliant role take care thanks
for being here thanks for your support
have yourselves a great evening
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit expressvpn